- One star.
Food here sucks.
Line way too long.
(laughter)
So that was his review of
the Great Wall of China.
- Oh my God.
- [Heben] Hi everyone, I'm Heben.
- [Tracy] I'm Tracy.
- [Heben] And welcome to Another
Round with Heben and Tracy.
"Is This Real Life?" is a segment where
we question reality collectively.
It is for situations where you're like,
"Did I read that right?
"Am I in the correct universe?
"The right timeline?"
Randomly, I was googling
the Great Wall of China
because I was amazed by it.
- Everyone does.
Yep, it's a big ass wall.
- And I was just like,
"I don't really know that much
about it, what's goin' on?"
And I noticed,
it says 1,897 reviews,
average 4.4.
(laughter)
So I was like, "What do you mean?"
- You can rate and review...
- Who rated the Great Wall of China?
So, the small description Google gives is
"Ancient world wonder that winds
"for more than 5,000 miles across China
"with towers and walkways."
- Sounds amazing.
- Yeah, ancient world
wonder, I'm in already.
(superficially clears her throat)
Lemme just review a snippet
of some of these reviews.
(laughter)
Three stars.
My child almost fell over
some stupid people running,
so I wouldn't recommend the Great Wall.
(laughter)
Dot dot dot, but the food was awesome.
Smiley face.
- What!?
- It was okay, but the
walking, dot dot dot
Eww.
(laughter)
- None of this is the Great
Wall of China's fault.
- So she got to the
Great Wall and was like,
"You know what, I'm walking too much.
"I did not anticipate this Great Wall
"including this many steps."
- This 5,000 plus mile-long walk.
- One star.
I had a, all caps, amazing time in China.
The Great Wall of China was
my favorite thing that I saw.
Awesome!
All caps, food was awful.
(laughter)
The view was terrible
and I almost fell off.
Plot twist, huh?
(laughter)
- Like, none of this is the fault...
- He wrote out plot twist,
though, I did not add that,
for the record.
Overall, I would rate it one out of five
That is 20%.
I am a math major.
(laughter)
Two stars.
The Great Wall of China is too damaged.
When it's fixed I will come again.
(laughter)
He was not impressed.
He's like, "Fix this shit."
Two stars.
It was okay.
The service was terrible
and the walk was a bit rocky
and too long for my liking.
Some good sites, but the staff was rude
and didn't speak English.
- Oh my God, how dare
they not speak English.
- Also, he spelt "too"
wrong in this review.
Sir, you barely speak English.
Five stars.
A real place to go when your
waiting for your husband
to finish up his Active rehab.
(laughter)
- What?
- I went to look to her profile
to see if there was more,
but there wasn't.
I'm so curious about her life.
- She was goin' through some stuff.
- They were goin' through it.
She's like, "Ya know what? Lemme hit up
" the Great Wall, though."
"This will help me get
solace at this time."
One star.
Why is there opening times?
It's a wall!
(laughter)
- Yeah, that's a good question, though.
How you gonna close a wall?
(laughter)
- And that concludes, "Is This Real Life?"
- Oh my gosh.
I would love to hear you just read reviews
of historical landmarks.
For like, hours.
- Oh man, Tracy.
This is gonna be a never ending segment.
I have so many of these.
- I'm both excited and really sad.